[Musik]
mit dem bericht
hallo
heute gibt es ein richtig leckeres
hauptgericht ich werde weitermachen und
zwar kenne ich das von meiner kritischen
freundin mit ihrem schiff während im
studium wirklich regelmäßig gemacht
immer waren der lernfahrer natürlich
wenn wo hatte man mehr zeit zum kochen
und weniger zu lernen vor ort mit einem
sehr gelungen ist unser letztes uplink
manöver heute mache ich es auch
ich kenne sie gesagt von meiner
kritischen freundin weiß aber auch dass
wir um arabischen und auch in den
nordafrikanischen raum sehr verbreitet
ist aber wie gesagt egal woher es kommt
hauptsache es schmeckt gut
ich zeige mich gleich mal die zutaten
hofacker besteht aus verschiedenen
schichten und fahrer werden auberginen
und kartoffeln angebraten dann mit einer
hackfleischsoße geschichtet und einer
dose und am ende mit hilfe im backofen
über wasser sprich slacker ein bisschen
aufwendig natürlich aber ist dann wird
es auf jeden fall einmal probieren
ich zeige euch hier vorne mal getraut
hatte für die hackfleisch losgebrochen
zwei esslöffeln olivenöl 500 starter
sind lacht eine zwiebel und
knoblauchzehen das wasser fließt ich an
formaten - geschälte tomaten auf verbote
hält noch die gewürze und pele preis auf
die tarnung ist und für die beste frau
mit jeweils kreativraum super und nähe
ich habe ich 500 medikaments da kommt
auch salz pfeffer und karthum freien und
habe ich noch drei maschinen etwa 800
gramm 800 gramm kartoffeln das playbook
geschälte gewicht also auch 800 gramm
und habe ich unsere gewachsen
jetzt mache ich zuerst einmal die
hackfleischsoße ihr könnt jetzt vieles
parallel arbeiten
ich setze die zuerst an das heißt im
topf kann ich jetzt schon mal einen fuß
und da ein bisschen öl rhein geben falls
das öl war mit geht ich hab gleich mit
dazu und kann die zwischenzeit von alu
von zwiebel und knoblauch hacken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das so und werden jetzt müsse angebraten
in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal
die aubergine in feinen scheiben
schneiden
bis sie vor nämlich einfach weg und
nehme hobel sie habe ich jetzt auf etwa
5 mm stärke eingestellt und kann das
jetzt hier für ein hoch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt um das tomatenmark meter zu fuß
mit angebraten und dann auch gleich mit
den tomaten aus der dose abgelöst wir
nehmen immer ganz gerne mal was erst
sehr reiche ernte freuen uns geht es
noch ein bisschen wasser das einfach
richtig schöne leckere soße bekomme und
dass die gewürze mit rein sowieso sie
darf dann erst einmal zwei wochen wäre
ich nicht hier um den rest zu machen
[Musik]
damit die auberginen jetzt ammann
bratenfett einbauen gebe es jetzt hier
in ein fazit von gestreute einfach mit
etwas salz klasse stehen und so kommt
einfach nach und nach feuchtigkeit aus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie kaufen haben jetzt bereits
aufgehoben ist bereits zuerst einmal die
chance mich jetzt hier die butter in
einem topf und mache eine mehlschwitze
jetzt geht es mir mit mit angebraten
[Musik]
wenn dann anfängt guten ist die
mehlschwitze soweit ich möchte herrn
schlimmste gefasst ist auf eine
hellbraune farbe wenn ihr gerne eine
klassikerin geschmack haben wollten mit
dem dunklen frauen werden lassen
jetzt gibt es vorbildlich die minister
so vorsichtig kann man sich schützen
aufkochen lassen und kann es hier schon
mal salz pfeffer und muskat ingwer zu
geben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die besser meint lohse die chips auch
die kleine herzklappe und lass dich hier
aufkochen und dann bei niedriger stufe
etwas 10 bis 15 minuten kochen
ich muss auch immer mal wieder rühren
damit sie einfach unten am topfboden
nichts anbrennen und kann erzählt die
herdplatte 05 und eine beschichtete
pfanne zu stellen habe das gleiche
gemüse drin angebraten und hier an der
seite kocht ihr auch noch die h2 stoße
das heißt wir ruhig auch immer mal
wieder um und schmeckt auch auf dem
gleis ist der falsche weg
diese frage selbst beziehungsweise aber
von beiden seiten was mit den kartoffeln
die auberginen sehen wir noch hier im
hintergrund und die werde ich das
abwaschen damit verschwindet ausführten
unseren ebenfalls aufpassen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt sind die letzten auberginen
schreiben auch angebraten und ich habe
jetzt immer schön auf die mit dem
küchenpapier einfach abtropfen lassen
damit ein bisschen fett ins futter weg
kommt jetzt wird das ganze gesicht ich
nehm ich hier so eine ovale auflaufform
da gebe ich jetzt zuerst einmal
kartoffeln rein und war die hälfte noch
nie zwei schichten übereinander schön
verteilt und die wirklichen gibt nicht
auf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da kommt jetzt mit auberginen server auf
die wirklich nicht sein
[Musik]
warum ist die hälfte der hat vielleicht
drüber
[Musik]
und jetzt haben sie gleich schlecht
einfach noch mal drauf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so fiel es felix loß braucht nämlich
besser als unter vom krise ein verein
bewegen und dann nehme ich jetzt eine
katze ihr könnt das was meinst du auch
im glauben nehmen und die versammelten
geben also einfach den käse nehmen wir
gerne habt oder die mittel richtig an
sagte besser wäre noch schön darüber
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das muss das bereits für den 8
[Musik]
so kommt es zu den vorgeheizten backofen
bei 200 grad ober unterhitze für etwa 35
minuten
natürlich nur mit einem backofen räumt
oder fertig und ich habe es ein bisschen
abkühlen lassen denn sonst muss ich mal
ganz schnell
so wie es jetzt aussieht finde es nicht
so gut aus und vor allem wie ich zittere
lecker und ich habe auch wirklich
ziemlich großen hunger vorab mittels
sagen komm wir machen jetzt auf dem
muster ein noch was machen wir in vier
wochen ist fertig das ist aber nicht
probieren denn das letzte stück was
gefehlt habe ich schon gesessen
daher ist die laune doch wieder
geschrieben weil der markt etwas ist
doch wohl bald wir dieses rezept nach
machen wollt was ich sehr hoffe wirklich
sehr woche denn es ist ein super
leckeres rezept
dann schaut auch verließ - blog.de
vorbei ich weise den aufwendig vor allem
wenn man hier das gemüse an warten muss
aber ich mache immer so ich bin frei
fand dafür berater parallel an dann ist
einfach ein bisschen schneller geht und
wenn man den rest von vorbereitet hat
funktioniert auch wirklich super also
probiert auch schreibt mir einen
kommentar wird euch geschmeckt hat und
da wünsche ich jetzt schon mal ein ganz
ganz guten appetit und bis zum nächsten
mal dass es lebt aber der kamera
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
das angucken
eine kamera reinkommt